[Música]
y
ustedes serían capaces de poder
imaginarse un mundo moderno sin plástico
un mundo sin botellas plásticas juguetes
plásticos o bolsas plásticas
difícil cierto de hoy casi todo lo que
ocupamos contiene plástico
y ahora quiero hacerles otra pregunta
ustedes serían capaces de poder imaginar
un mundo en donde en el mar haya más
plástico que peces
soy una locura pero aquí a 30 años la
producción de plástico se triplicará y
con esto podría ser una completa
realidad
me gustaría que se acuerden de algunas
veces haber visto una bolsa flotando en
el aire las típicas bolsas supermercados
que se pueden ver en casi todas las
calles
dónde estará
estará sola
existe la posibilidad de que esa bolsa
formé parte de verdaderas islas de
plástico que estaban contaminando
nuestro cero
estos monstruos se alimentan de la cerca
de 8 millones de toneladas que ingresan
anualmente es como si tú tuviera un
camión de basura y cada 30 segundos
vertir a su carga al mar
con todo esto y el lugar en el mundo
está libre de plástico las playas
los polos árticas y antárticas
en las profundidades
esta fotografía corresponde a la fuerza
de las marianas el lugar más profundo de
todo el planeta y ya se ha encontrado
plástico y no sólo eso los seres vivos
que habitan en su profundidad se lo
están comiendo
comiendo
cómo podemos llegar algún ser vivo que
vive en lo más profundo de nuestro
océano si se coma el plástico
es súper común poder decir que el
plástico se degrada si se degrada pero
se demora más de 100 años quiero
contarles que nosotros les si no
ocupamos el plástico desde los años 50 y
no han pasado 100 años de eso
todo el plástico que alguna de la
historia se fabricó en este minuto
siendo las
investigaciones que demuestran que el
consumo de plástico
el selectivo existe hay varias y siempre
me pasa que cuando se las comenta algún
amigo algún compañero me responde algo
como pobre animalitos pero tu bebé puede
afectar a mí
a lo que yo respondo en que nosotros si
consumimos productos del mar
y que si nosotros consumimos esos
productos que están contaminados
directamente vamos a consumir
contaminación por plástico
un estudio realizado por el grupo de la
revista 'nature en california y en
indonesia detectó que uno de cada tres
productos del mercado contenían
contaminación por plástico positiva si
ustedes compran tres peces uno iba estar
contaminado
qué está pasando en chile
tendremos contaminación por plástica
hace poco aparece un estudio en
centollas en cabo de hornos bien al sur
y se detectó que el 27 por ciento de las
muestras estudiadas tenían contaminación
positiva es como si usted es como si tú
fueras con tres amigos un restaurant de
lujo
pidiera un plato de centolla y a uno de
los cuatro le aparecieron trozos azul
que probablemente fuera plástico y está
pasando allí el chile
nuestro océano plástico es un tema de
contingencia
está pasando ahora
entonces dentro de mis reflexiones yo
pensaba porque las personas lo
desconocen si yo le contaba esta
investigación en algún compañero pasaba
en que me decían muchas interesantes
llevaran que qué bueno que te está
interesando estas cosas pero realmente
se desconoce la realidad y el trasfondo
que tiene
es súper peligroso
porque ahora en este minuto nosotros
estamos desconociendo un tema de
trascendencia
con el tiempo
dentro de mi cuestionamiento me
preguntaba por qué esas personas no
sabían eso
porque desconocían una parte importante
de la realidad
y así en el colegio me di cuenta que
sentado con mis compañeros de curso en
una sala como todos pasamos alguna vez
en nuestra vida nunca un profe me dijo
oye ojo con esto o ojo con esto otro
porque puede estar causando
repercusiones ecológicas y les pregunto
ustedes alguna vez con su colega de
trabajo camino al trabajo almorzando en
el casino and hablaba este tema de
contaminación por plástico no creo
pero en realidad
y yo
soy un convencido de que el poder de lo
real marca la diferencia para poder
cambiar las cosas
si te muestran algo que para ti te hace
sentido si te muestran algo que a ti te
interesa y que te deja una pequeña marca
te va a cambiar la percepción del mundo
te va a poder cambiar la forma en que tú
aprecias y eres capaz de ver lo que está
pasando
pero ahora
qué podemos hacer nosotros
tengo la clave
la clave
para hacer cualquier cosa debe salir con
la persona que te gusta a intentar hacer
un movimiento a intentar cambiar el
mundo es demostrar interés y llevarlo a
la acción
chile lo ha hecho
es el primer país en américa que
implementó una ley para disminuir el
consumo de bolsa plástica en comunas
costeras eliminando las y desde el 2013
ya ha hecho iniciativas para poder
regular las sumándose a países como
argentina alemania eeuu méxico china
entre otros que están marcando una
diferencia positiva
qué podemos hacer nosotros primero
apoyemos esta iniciativa apoyamos le
hemos visto bueno
pongamos este tema sobre la mesa
de donde yo quiero invitarles a cumplir
estos cinco principios
rechaza
si notan algo de plástico porque
aceptarlo siempre
prepara a nuestro hijo algún niño se le
rompió su juguete porque lo desechamos
el tiro y no buscamos alguna forma de
poder arreglarlo
y luego utiliza
cuántos de acá han ocupado más de 345
veces los utensilios desechables que nos
pasan para poder comer
bien los felicito
también podemos dejar llegar nuestra
imaginación hace poco tuve la
oportunidad de ir a san martín de los
andes argentina esta es una pequeña
ciudad al sur de argentina en donde se
caracteriza por el elevado turismo y el
turismo va en borde de su lago que es
agua y que lo cuidan como vuestro santo
y en la plaza me encontré de que el
árbol de navidad estaba hecho totalmente
con botellas plásticas que normalmente
aquí nosotros desechamos
y no sólo eso
los basureros que estaban en la ciudad
también
por último
podemos rediseñar y es aquí en donde
vengo a contar la historia de roberto él
es un padre de familia de tome que
inventó unas bolsas que además de ser
biodegradables se son solubles en agua
esto significa que si la bolsa toca el
mar se va a degradar y no va a
contaminar ni con plástico en ni
siquiera el agua debido a los materiales
que está hecho
es una oportunidad para innovar siendo
amigable con el medio ambiente
por último
y ahora que todos acá saber un poco más
de este tema lo invito a que lo hablen
con un familiar con un amigo con un
colega quizás hasta con alguien el amigo
porque porque ustedes son capaces de
aportar con su granito de arena si
hablan de educación porque con eso ya
están luchando contra la contaminación
muchas gracias
[Música]
y